hi herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid heute
mit einem Ukraine Update zur
militärischen Lage im Süden des Landes
schaffen es offenbar immer mehr Truppen
über den Dnipro den Fluss und auf die
Russisch kontrollierte Seite und
gleichzeitig Schein in aftiivka also im
Osten der Ukraine die russischen Truppen
im Kampf um die Stadt zuletzt
Fortschritte gemacht zu haben über diese
zwei Frontabschnitte also über den Süden
und über den Osten und auch darüber
welche Bedeutung drohen und Störsender
im Verlauf dieses Krieges gewonnen haben
darüber sprechen wir heute zum einen mit
Oberst Markus Reisner in Wien und mit
unserem ZDF Reporter Dara Hassan
Entschuldigung mit unserem ZDF Reporter
Dara hassanade in kieev und wie immer in
dieser Sendung auch mit euch da draußen
wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt zu den
verschiedenen Front Abschnitten oder zum
Verlauf des Krieges oder eure Meinung zu
diesen Themen mit uns teilen wollt dann
schreibt uns immer einfach hier im
Youtube Chat oder per Mail an die
eingeblendete Adresse jetzt schauen wir
aber erstmal über die aktuelle Lage in
der Ukraine
ukrainische Soldaten unterwegs in einem
Boot ein Video das auf der Plattform Ex
aufgetaucht ist es könnte vom tpro
stammen doch das lässt sich nicht
hundertprozentig
ein weiteres Video soll zeigen wie auf
der linken Flussseite beim Ort krinki
Schützengräben der Russen per Drohne
angegriffen
werden die Videos decken sich mit der
Nachricht dass ukrainische Truppen den
Fluss tnibro bei Cherson überquert haben
und in Russisch besetztes Gebiet
vorstoßen konnten das räumte auch der
von den Russen eingesetzte Gouverneur in
der Region ein für die Ukraine ein
wichtiger militärischer
Erfolg anders die Lage nah afdivka im
Osten des Landes Ukrainer feuern gegen
die russischen Truppen die haben in den
letzten Wochen ihre Angriffe verstärkt
dagegen stand zu halten wird schwieriger
denn die Russen haben ihre Taktik
geändert permanent attackieren sie mit
kleinen Kampfeinheiten erzählt ein
ukrainischer
Offizier sie kommen nicht so vorwärts
wie sie dachten sie machen es jetzt
anders sie greifen in kleinen Gruppen an
mit 3 bis 15 Leuten
Russlands Truppen haben laut
Militärexperten zuletzt Fortschritte im
Kampf um afdivka erzieltt offenbar
versuchen sie die Stadt einzukreisen
gleichzeitig erlitten sie laut Ukraine
schwere Verluste in
avdevka einst mehr als 30.000 Einwohner
ist kein einziges Haus mehr intakt nur
noch etwa 1500 Menschen sind hier und
versuchen irgendwie zu
überleben ja und über diese zwei Punkte
an der der Front spreche ich jetzt mit
Militärexperte Oberst Markus Reisner
wenn ihr diese Sendung öfter guckt dann
kennt ihr ihn schon er leit die
Entwicklungsabteilung an der
Theresianischen Militärakademie in Wien
und ist Kommandant des österreichischen
gardebataillons von 2004 bis 2013 war
Reisner Teil einer Spezialeinheit des
österreichischen bundesheirs und nahm an
verschiedenen ausle Auslandseinsätzen
teil und jetzt sollte er mir
zugeschaltet sein guten Abend Herr
Reisner schön dass Sie bei uns sind
guten Abend liebe Grüße aus Wien Herr
Reisner bisher lief die Front entlang
dieses flussist niepro der ist ja also
eine große natürliche Barriere jetzt
haben in die Ukrainer bei krinki
überquert und bringen immer mehr Truppen
rüber was glauben Sie wie entscheidend
ist dieser Erfolg der
Ukrainer n diese Erfolge sind zurzeit
ganz entscheidend weil es geht hier vor
allem um einen Erfolg im sogenannten
Informationsraum im informationsd
und hier muss die Ukraine zeigen dass
sie trotz der schweren Kämpfe in auf
diefk als im Osten der Ukraine sehr wohl
das Momentum auf ihrer Seite hat und
darum sind diese Flussüberquerungen ganz
entscheidend weil es ist nicht nur so
dass sie wasasi hier tatsächlich Fuß
fassen auf der anderen Uferseite sondern
auch es schaffen substanziell Material
und Soldaten auf die andere Seite zu
bekommen und das könnte natürlich der
Ausgangspunkt sein in quasi der Form
eines Brückenkopfes für weitere
Operationen gegen die russische Kräfte
südlich des
Nebo und genau zu diesem Brückenkopf
haben wir schon eine Frage aus der
Community auf Youtube fragt jemand BGT
ein Brückenkopf nicht die Gefahr an sich
dass dieser mit massivem Artillerie
Feuer vernichtet werden kann was bringt
ein Brückenkopf konkret angesichts
dieser
Gefahr ja das ist natürlich korrekt wie
gesagt hier steht vor allem im
Vordergrund der Umstand dass die Ukraine
hiermit zeigen kann dass ist ja wohl
auch ein Gewissen Abschnitten der Front
in die Offensive gehen kann ein Momentum
zeigen kann was sie gemacht hat und das
hat sie jar überlegt gemacht sie hat
also versucht quasi das sogenannte
elektromagnetische Feld mit eigenen
störsystemen entsprechend zu sättigen
was meine ich damit dass ist jenes Feld
wo im Prinzip auf verschiedenen
Frequenzbändern gefunkt wird wo die
Kommunikation mit z.B drohen stattfindet
aufklärungsdrohen aber auch
wirkungsdrohen wo aber auch die
Kommunikation zur Artillerie z.B
stattfindet oder quasi auch zwischen den
gefechtsständen oder den Teileinheiten
und die Ukraine hat also hier einiges an
störsindern zusammen gesammelt und hat
es quasi hier versucht eine Art Blase zu
bilden und der sie quasi im Schutz auch
der zu diesem Zeit sehr günstigen
nebeligen Situationen morgen meistens es
geschafft hat der Soldaten auf der
andereen Seite zu bringen zuerst den
kleinen Gruppen dann immer größer und
mittlerweile kann man davon ausgehen
dass C ein bataillonsoldaten sich hier
verschanzt hat das sind ca 4 500 Mann
und diese bereiten den Russen schwere
Probleme was meine ich damit die Russen
sind jetzt natürlich gefordert
Ressourcen die sie vielleicht an andere
Stelle brauchen würden umzuleiten das
sind es einerseits Kräfte die sie
brauchen um diesen Brückenkopf
abzuriegeln aber natürlich Artillerie
die sie verschieben müssen oder auch im
Prinzip Fähigkeiten der Luftstreitkräfte
kampfschauer und ähnliches um diesen
Brückenkopf zu bekämpfen ja und sie
sprechen da auch schon ein Thema an was
wir uns heute mal genauer angucken
wollen ein Teil des Erfolges liegt
nämlich in Störsendern die die Ukraine
für sich nutzen was glauben sind die
glauben denn sie welche Rolle spielen
drohen aber auch Störsender für diesen
Krieg mittlerweile auf beiden
Seiten ja sie spielen eine entscheidende
Rolle mittlerweile man hat es auch sehr
gut nach lesen können in dem kürzlich
von General saluschni verfassten
schreiben hier hat also einige sehr
konkrete Aussagen gemacht und er hat
also gesagt er braucht in dieser
Situation jetzt die quasi mehr oder
weniger einem atchach gleicht also quasi
einem Unentschieden einer patsituation
braucht er quasi zusätzliche Mittel er
hat gemeint quasi ähnlich wie derfindung
des schwarzpulfers durch die Chinesen
und das meint er hier er meint die
Situation ist zu vergleichen mit einem
Art gläernen Gefechtsfeld beide Seiten
können sich gegenseitig beobachten vor
allem durch den Einsatz von vielen
tausenden Drohnen die gleichzeitig am
Himmel sind dadurch kann keine Seite
wirklich Kräfte bereitstellen und die
dann ins Manöver führen sie kann es nur
dann wenn es gelingt diese Drohnen vom
Himmel zu holen und das kann man vor
allem in dem man quasi die Kommunikation
dieser Drohnen unterbricht damit sie
quasi nicht fliegen können und dann hat
man die Möglichkeit tatsächlich dem
Gegner im Prinzip die Sicht V un zu
unmöglichen oder bzw auch zu verhindern
dass es eine Waffenwirkung durch diese
drohen einsetzen kann und das ist dann
die Chance wo sie antreten können das
Dilemma ist die Front ist ca 1200 km
lang das wäre so wenn sie in Berlin ins
aut steigen und bis nach Florenz fahren
oder nach London und hier hat die
Ukraine natürlich nur begrenzt Mitteln
aber es kann also sehr gut hier erkannt
werden dass wenn die Ukraine die
richtige Mitteln hat dann kann sie
regionale überlegenheiten schaffen die
dann sehr wohl zu erfolgen sich
entsprechend umwandeln lassen sie
sprechen gerade von richtigen Mitteln
welchen wären das denn in dieser
Situation ganz
konkret n konkret geht es jetzt
natürlich
für die Ukraine V allem auf drei eben um
entscheidende Fragen wir haben also im
Militär die strategische Ebene die
operative und die taktische Ebene auf
strategische Ebene ist es für die
Ukraine jetzt wichtig quasi durch den
Winter zu kommen sie wissen auch der
ukrainische militärnachrichtendienst
weist darauf hin dass die Russen
möglicherweise über 1000
marschflugkörperballistische Raketen und
zusätzlich noch iranische Drohnen
bereitgestellt haben um wieder die
kritische Infrastruktur des Landes so
wie letzten Winter anzugreifen und das
zu verhindern braucht die Ukraine quasi
auf strategische Ebene fliegerbysteme
damit die Tiefe ihres Raum schützen kann
auf operativever Ebene ist es so dass
die Ukraine jetzt vorbereitet werden
muss für eine mögliche Offensive früher
wenn die Ukraine nach wie vor und das
ist ja das Ziel in der Lage sein soll
quasi die besetzten Gebiete von den
Russen zu befreien und wenn wir dran
denken dass durch die offensiv im Sommer
signifikant Gerät verbraucht worden ist
dann muss natürlich hier nachgeschoben
werden das heiß es geht also darum sich
in den nächsten Monaten zu konsolidieren
und alle Fähigkeiten zusammenzubringen
die man braucht möglicherweise zu diesem
Zeitpunkt dann im frühah auch schon
durch den Einsatz von Kampfflugzeugen
vom f16 oder anderen Fähigkeiten auf der
taktischen Ebene auf der untersten Ebene
wo wir da wo wir jetzt auch sehen diese
Gefechte bei grinki z.B da ist es
wichtig quasi sich so zu konsolidieren
dass man die Voraussetzungen schafft
auch durch die kalte Jahreszeit zu
kommen das heißt man braucht also Räume
wo man mehr oder weniger geschützt aber
auch gesichert gegenüber der Witterung
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten diese
verbringen kann und sich vorbereiten
kann auf den nächsten Schritt und das
versucht die Ukraine jetzt die versucht
jetzt gerade noch in der günstigen Zeit
die Voraussetzungen zu schaffen für
diese schwierige Winterzeit und und vor
allem auch im Informationsraum das
Momentum für sich zu
behalten lassen Sie uns noch mal kurz
auf den Einsatz der Drohnen bzw der
Störsender kommen hier fragt nämlich
gerade jemand aus der Community ist
funkstören nicht ein zweischneidiges
Schwert weil man sich auch selber stört
dadurch natürlich das ist der Fall der
Punkt ist natürlich wenn man das geplant
tut dann kann man die eigigen Maßnahmen
natürlich darauf abstimmen da weiß man
dass man in gewissen Zeitfenstern z.B
über keine Kommunikation verfügt weil
jetzt gerade ade die eigenen Störer
versuchen den Gegner zu stören der ja
damit in der Sekunde nicht rechnen kann
das heißt das muss man sehr genau
synchronisieren um genau diesen Effekt
zu verhindern und es gibt auch andere
Möglichkeiten gerade auch heute mit den
technologischen Möglichkeiten die wir
zur Verfügung haben wo man also diese
Dinge etwas umgehen kann wenn man
natürlich weiß was für Geräte der Gegner
hat und wie kann ich ja darauf reagieren
drum ist es auch so wichtig dass von der
russischer Seite immer wieder gerät
erbeutet wird das kann analysiert werden
daraus kann man Ableitungen treffen man
weiß die Frequenzbänder man weiß wie man
also diese stören kann und das ist auch
das was die Ukraine versucht durch unter
also unter anderem erst in den letzten
Monaten entwickeltes Gerät einzusetzen
was das quasi hier genau diesen
entscheidenden Unterschied
macht ja und jetzt haben wir da um
krinki auf jeden Fall eine besondere
Situation im Süden der Ukraine in der
die Ukrainer in einem Vorteil sind wie
reagieren denn die Russen aktuell auf
diesen
Vorteil nun man muss natürlich das sehen
immer quasi in die Ausdehnung der Front
betrachten diesen 1200 km und man muss
es einbetten in alle Domäne der
Kriegsführung es geht also hier vor
allem um das zeigen dass man das
Momentum hat der Brückenkopf selber hat
eine überschaubare Größe und Ausdehnung
wenn er wirklich quasi die Basis sein
sollte für eine größere Offensive da
muss er natürlich mit Kräften genährt
werden es müssen vor allem mechanisierte
gepanzerte Kräfte kommen es muss also
zusätzliches materiale herangeeführt
werden es müssen leistungsfähige
Pontonbrücken errichtet werden die nicht
von der russischen Seite wieder zerstört
werden dürfen dann hat man einen
tatsächlichen tragfähigen Übergang und
kann von diesem Punkt dann ausgehend
möglicherweise weiter Richtung Süden
vorstoßen und theoretisch auch die Dinge
erreichen die man eigentlich im Sommer
versucht hat und die nicht gelungen sind
diese operative Durchbruch zuum m offen
steht das tatsächlich zu bestimmen ob
das funktioniert das ist noch zu früh
die russische Seite versucht es
natürlich zu verhindern sieht die
Situation jetzt noch nicht gefährdend
man sieht es sehr gut dass sie zwar
Ressourcen umschichten aber nicht
entscheidende Ressourcen umschichten die
haben Sie nach wie vor an anderer Stelle
wie z.B bei auf diefk oder nördlich
davon bei kupiansk swow wo sie versuchen
scheinbar ebenfalls vor dem Winter noch
eine Entscheidung herbeizuführen und
hier drängt sich natürlich die Situation
auf be diefka im Vergleich mit bagmut wo
es nach heftigen Kämpfen damals die
Stadt gefallen ist und das versuchte
natürlich jetzt Russland ebenfalls
durchzuführen um einen weiteren Erfolg
zu erzielen bzw um von dort ausgehen
natürlich weitere Erfolge zu erzielen zu
können wie z.B der Stoß Richtung Marinka
oder uklbeitere Städte dort in diesem
Bereich südlich von auf diefk wir hören
ja auch von einem gleitbombeneinsatz von
russischer Seite ist das etwas was an
diesem Frontabschnitt aktuell auch zum
Tragen
kommt genau das ist der Fall die Russen
haben in den letzten Monaten es
geschafft tatsächlich dumme
freifallbomben durch einen
entsprechenden
zusatzausstattungssatz so zu befehgen
quasi dass sie in der Lage sind a
sicherer Distanz in den Einsatz
geschickt zu werden die Bombe gleitet
quasi auf Flügeln die sie auskappen kann
präzisionsgesteuert durch das russische
klonas in das Ziel wir sehen das sehr
gut auf den Aufnahmen die jeden da
reinkommen es sind meistens zwei
Einschläge warum weil ein dertiges
kampflugzeug links und rechts gr unter
den Tragflächen eine dertige Fab 500
1000 oder 1500 die Zahl steht für das
Gewicht mitführt und das ist ein gutes
Zeichen an dem man erkennen kann dass
die Russen sehr wohl in der Lage sind
sich anzupassen was ist das
entscheidende das ist die die Distanz
das heiß durch dem Umstand dass die
Russen diese bomb sichere Distanz
abförren können sind sie nicht bedroht
durch die flügabehr der Ukraine vor
allem durch die mittlere fliegabwehr bzw
auch durch diese Stör Systeme und das
macht diese Waffen so verherend das
Problem ist sie brauchen natürlich für
diesen Einsatz eine präzise
zielbeobachtung sie müssen also genau
wissen wo diese Bomben quasi im Prinzip
einschlagen sollen und da tun sich die
Russen schwer weil sie eben unmittelbar
vor Ort die Drohne die sie dafür
verwenden zur Zeit teilweise nicht
verwenden können weil diese gestört
werden durch diese störsysteme der
Ukraine regional begrenzt aber natürlich
an diesem Raum in diesem Raum
krinki ja und eine letzte Frage noch zum
südlichen Bereich der Front kommt aus
der Community der fragt
jemand stimmen die Posts wonach die
Ukrainer schon bis zu 8 km über den
Fluss in Richtung Krim vorgestossßen
sind weil auf den deepstate Maps ist das
noch nicht
eingezeichnet nein da muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein mit diesen Meldungen die
natürlich aus den sozialen Netzwerken
kommen auch gespeist von beiden Seiten
hier natürlich auf der russischen Seite
der Versuch quasi die eigenen Erfolge zu
überhöhen und natürlich von der
ukrainischen Seite der Versuch mögliche
Verluste möglichst lange geheim zu
halten ich kann Ihnen sagen sie müssen
wirklich tatsächlich hier jene Bilder
heranziehen die Ihnen zur Verfügung
stehen dazu muss man sagen auch hier
sind die sozialen Netzwerke sehr
umfangreich aber wenn Sie Bilder sehen
von z.B ukrainischen Soldaten auf der
anderen Flussseite wenn Sie diese
georeferenzieren können wenn sie
tatsächlich sagen können ja das ist das
Haus da ist der ukrainische Soldat wir
haben jetzt zwei drei Videos aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven dann ist es
ein erstes Indiz wo sich die vordersten
Truppen quasi der Ukraine befinden oder
auch umgekehrt der russischen Seite
sonst muss man also sehr vorsichtig sein
mit diesen Meldungen die hier verbreitet
werden lassen Sie uns jetzt mal vom
Süden der Ukraine weiter östlich an die
Front gehen in afdivka sollen russische
Truppen die Stadt aktuell einkesseln wie
bedrohlich ist die Lage dort aus ihrer
Perspektive nun wir haben jetzt im
Prinzip den zweiten Winter der für uns
steht und wenn wir im Vergleich
betrachten den letzten Winter dann hat
man erkennen können dass eso damals die
Russen ihre sogenannte Winteroffensive
in der Form durchgeführt haben dass sie
einerseits versucht haben an
verschiedenen Stellen vorzustoßen das
war z Fall z.B bei ugled da wo sie sehr
schwere Verluste litten haben aber
andererseits auch versucht hab an
verschiedenen Stellen gleichzeitig
anzugreifen um die Ukraine zu zwingen
ihre kostbaren Reserven auszuspielen
damals war es so dass die Russen bereits
abgezielt haben auf die strategischen
Reserven die die Ukraine bereitgestellt
hat für dann die folgende
Sommeroffensive diese z Reserven diese
Brigaden der Reserve im Wesentlichen der
Offensive als solches was wir jetzt
sehen ist da ein ähnliches Bild auch
hier versucht Russland an verschiedenen
Stellen anzugreifen einerseits natürlich
mit der Absicht tatsächlich bodengewinne
zu haben aber andererseits auch um die
Ukraine zu zwingen wieder ihre kostbaren
Reserven auszuspielen man sieht das sehr
gut an einem Beispiel die 47 ukrainische
mechtbrigade war eigentlich eine der
Brigaden der Offensive eine dieser
reservebrigaden die wurde im Sommer
eingesetzt im Zentralraum nördlich von
militopol und wurde jetzt verlegt in den
Raum auf dieevka wo sie gemeinsam mit
der ersten
Panzerbrigade versucht wasas sie
tatsächlich sich bereitzustellen für
mögliche notwendige Gegenangriffe gegen
die russischen Kräfte die in einer
Zangenbewegung versuchen
vorzumarschieren wenn die Stadt auf
diefk fehlt so ist es natürlich im
Informationsraum für die russische Seite
ein Erfolg es ist aber gleichzeitig ein
Erfolg dahingehend dass Russland von
diesem eingenommenen Raum aus weiter
Richtung Süden angreifen kann also
Richtung Marinka und von dort weiter
Richtung ugleda das heißt es scheint so
als ob Russland versucht in
zangenbewegungen sich einstück nach dem
anderen aus dem ukrainischen Territorium
herauszubeißen und offensichtlich ist es
so dass Verluste und man sieht ja auf
den Bilder dass hier horende Verluste
entstehen müssen offensichtlich keine
Rolle
spielen ja Stichwort Verluste von
Reserven und auch abnutzungskrieg hier
fragt jemand aus der Community beide
Seiten erleiden Verluste an Material und
Menschenleben welche dieser Kategorien
wird für welche Seite am Ende
entscheidend
sein nun wenn man das das jetzt ganz
klar herunterbricht auf das whrpotenzial
des jeweiligen Landes und seiner
Bevölkerung dann drängt sich natürlich
ein Vorteil für Russland auf weil wir
auf der einen Seite 145 Millionen
Menschen haben nämlich dass die
russische Bevölkerung mit ein
entsprechenden whrpotenzial im Vergleich
zur ukrainischen Bevölkerung wenn man
die geflüchteten wegrechnet ca zwischen
33 und 35 Millionen Menschen wo eso
quasi natürlich das whrpotenzial
begrenzt ist wir hören also immer mehr
dass eso viele der Soldaten die
ausgebildet werden auch in den
natokursen mittlerweile 50 60 Jahre alt
sind das Durchschnittsalter s knapp über
40 sein haben die Ukraine selbst jetzt
vor kurzem angegeben und das zeigt
natürlich dass wenn die Ukraine immer
nur nur stückweise vom Westen Material
bekommt dass es nicht diesen schnellen
Erfolg geben wird und dass die Ukraine
gezwungen ist natürlich immer mehr
Soldaten entsprechend zu rekrutieren und
auch in den Einsatz zu schicken und wenn
offensichtlich Russland nicht das
Problem hat quasi mit Verlusten
entsprechende Problem Herausforderungen
zu haben dann ist natürlich der
Vergleich klar dass also hier Russland
den Vorteil hat und das macht es ja auch
so dringlich hinsichtlich der
Hilfslieferung an die Ukraine weil die
Zeit einfach endlich
ist ja so viel einmal zum Zustand äh der
Armeen jetzt fragt sich noch an diesem
Frontabschnitt im Osten rund um aftiivka
mit welchem Gerät sind denn dort die
Ukraine aktuell
aufgestellt ja wir haben im Kern und da
erzähle ich Ihnen nichts Geheimes das
ist sogenanntes Open Source intelligence
wissen also im Prinzip Dinge die Sie
also ganz normal aus dem Internet auch
verfügbar haben sie müssen es halt mit
einer prechend militärischen Analyse
verfügen wir haben im Kern also mehrere
Einheiten in auf die FK selber das sind
das Einheiten die zum Teil vor allem
infanristische Einheiten sind also mit
Masse maximal motorisiert und es sind
zum Teil auch mechanisierte Einheiten
hier gibt es also drei stärkere
Einheiten mechanisierte Einheiten die
unmittelbar in auf diefka sind die auch
versuchen was sie die russischen Kräfte
zu binden und dann haben wir zwei
brigadeäquivalente das sind also mehrere
1us Soldaten die 47 und die erste
Panzerbrigade etwas weiter westlich von
aufdfka das waren also möglich das wä
mögliche Kräfte die man bereitstellen
kann und sie dann in Gegenangriffen
einsetzen kann was auch passiert die 47
mchtbrigade das WI wir aufgrund der
Bilder auch der beschädigten und
zerstörten leopardo und bradyley die
versuchen also gerade hier den Russen
nordwestlich von auftefka bei der
eisenbarnine entsprechend einen Riegel
vorzuschieben damit diese nicht weiter
vorstoßen können auf der russischen
Seite haben wir eine ähnliche Situation
wir haben also auch hier mechanisierte
motorisierte Verbände die haben in den
letzten Wochen sehr schwere Verluste
erlitten und jetzt scheint es dass sie
quasi ihre Taktik verändern sie setzen
jetzt also sehr schwergewichtsmäßig
first person view Drohnen ein das sind
Drohnen die man sehr gezielt mit
sprengstoffbaden in erkannte Ziele
tatsächlich steuern kann und sie setzen
eine Art Sturm und stoßtrupptaktik ein
wo sie in kleinen Gruppen von wenigen
Mann bis zu Zugstärke sind ungefähr 30
40 Mann versuchen was ist sich Meter für
Meter vorzuarbeiten so wie die Ukrainer
das machen im Zentralraum nördlich von
militopol und
merpol so viel erstmal zu diesem
Frontabschnitt danke bis hierhin Herr
Reisner wir weiten gleich den Blick noch
mal und gucken auf den anstehenden
Winter und auch darauf was westliche
Unterstützer liefern werden und Aussicht
der Ukraine vielleicht liefern müssten
vielen
Dank so und jetzt spreche ich noch mal
mit ZDF Reporter Dara Hassan Sade dessen
Name ich natürlich kenne weil wir an
dieser Stelle schon ganz oft gesprochen
haben der uns jetzt live aus Kiev
zugeschaltet ist guten Abend
Dara hallo und Dara ist vollkommen
ausreichend wunderbar dar Russland wird
ja im Winter die drohen und
Raketenangriffe auf die Energie
Infrastruktur der Ukraine verstärken das
sagte jetzt auch schon der ukrainische
Präsident selenski bekommt man jetzt
gerade bei dir in Kiev da wo du stehst
schon was mit
davon ja in Kiev war es jetzt ruhig vor
allem die letzten zwei Tage seitdem wir
hier sind es gab mehrfach Luftalarm
allerdings keine Luftangriffe Luftalarm
bedeutet hier für die Stadt allerdings
schon große Einschränkung nicht dass
jeder dann sofort in den Bunker gehen
würde meistens die meisten ukra gerade
hier in Kiev ignorieren ihn aber die
Brücken über den knieprro werden
gesperrt und man kann nicht drüber
fahren und damit ist gerade für die
Pendler die die Stadt dann zu den
berufsstunden verlassen wollen ein
Riesenstau da der letzte Luftangriff war
Anfang der Woche doch es rechnet jeder
hier damit dass ich dieses Szenario des
letzten Jahres diese dieses massive
bombardieren von Infrastruktur die auch
zum Teil mitten in der Stadt angegriffen
wurde mit all den Kollateralschäden wie
das in der Militärsprache heißt
wiedereereignen kann man fühlt sich so
ein bisschen wie die Ruhe vor dem Sturm
und darauf hat Präsident selenski
hingewiesen und das empfindet eigentlich
nicht nur die Bevölkerung in Kiev so
sondern das habe ich schon die ganze
Zeit in den letzten vier Wochen die ich
hier durchs Land gereist bin von Lemberg
bis nach hakif überall gespürt alle
rechnen mit diesen Angriffen in diesem
Winter die Militär precherin humenjuk
der Südfront hat heute noch mal deutlich
gemacht dass sie davon ausgeht dass
Russland allein in auf der Krim 800
Marschflugkörper deponiert habe diese
Marschflugkörper liegen in Depots in
Bunkern und sind für die ukrainische
Armee im Moment nicht so erreichen und
aus Sicht des ukrainischen Militärs wird
dann natürlich der Ruf nach exakt der
tauruswaffe die Deutschland im Moment
Moment noch nicht liefert natürlich laut
und die Politiker unterstützen das und
da liegt auch glaube ich eine ganz große
Unterschiedlichkeit in der Bewertung von
Eskalation während des Kanzleramt darauf
hinweist dass man nur diese Waffe nicht
liefern will weil man auch eine
Eskalation des Krieges fürchtet will
Kiev vor allem diese Arsenale
unschädlich machen bevor sie zum Einsatz
kommen und würde genau den Einsatz
dieser taurusrakete die bunkerbrechend
sein kann dann als
deeskalieren deeskalierend bewerten mhm
also eine gewisse Ruhe vor dem Sturm von
der du da sprichst welche Vorkehrungen
treffen die Ukrainer und Ukrainerinnen
denn jetzt
schon zum einen ähm sind sie haben sie
sind die Erfahrungen absolut Präsent vom
letzten Winter der für ganz viele
Menschen ja richtig furchtbar war es gab
keine Luftabwehr das muss man sich immer
wieder vor Augen führen das hieß dass
fast jeder abgeschossene russische
Rakete auch wirklich eingeschlagen ist
und äh die
Stromversorgung ging in die Knie es
gegen
die Wasserwerke konnten nicht arbeiten
weil kein Strom für die Pumpen da waren
Heizung fehlte das war das Leben dass
die Leute hier hatten und sie haben sich
natürlich privat vorbereitet aber ich
habe auch mit Energieversorgern
gesprochen z.B mit dtech eines der
größten Energieversorger in diesem Land
die haben ganz enorm Vorkehrungen
getroffen was z.B Umspannwerke trifft
weil Sie festgestellt haben dass die
Treffer auf ihre Kraftwerke gar nicht so
verheerend waren wie die Treffer auf
Umspannwerke da die Transformation ähm
Transformatoren nicht so schnell zu
reparieren waren und deshalb wurden die
enorm geschützt zum einen durch die
Armee durch luftab durch Flugabwehr
gerade V westlicher Natur durch Patriot
Systeme z.B aber auch ganz einfach
physisch durch Betonschalen durch
Sandsäcke so dass ähm äh sie hoffen dass
wenn größer selbst wenn größere Raketen
einschlagen würden aus Russland dass der
Schaden nicht so groß wäre was ist denn
der Grund dafür dass diese Angriffe noch
nicht begonnen haben wir gehen ja
wirklich in großen Schritten Richtung
Winter ich bin natürlich ein bisschen
zum Spekulieren gezwungen weil ich
mich überhaupt ja was ist der Zweck
dieses Krieges
aus russischer Sicht m ein ein eine
Motivation da bin ich mir relativ sicher
im letzten Winter war dass die russische
Seite glaubte die ukrainische Wirtschaft
durch diese massive Bombardierung
landesweit gegen die Infrastruktur in
die Knie zu bringen dass das Land
wirtschaftlich zusammenbrechen wird und
deswegen dann einfach auch nicht länger
an der Front standhalten kann und die
zweite Hoffnung war bestimmt auch dass
diese Härte die gerade der
Zivilbevölkerung zugemutet wurde nicht
nur dass sie frieren und
Todesangst ausstehen musste sondern auch
dass sie ähm wirklich getötet wurden
durch
durch diese Einschläge dass diese
Bevölkerung aufgibt und seine und die
eigene Regierung dazu animiert doch in
Verhandlungen zu treten und sich M ja zu
kapitulieren da ich glaube diese
Hoffnung spülte auf der russischen Seite
schon mit das Ergebnis war dass der
Westen Flugabwehr geliefert hat und das
Ergebnis war dass die UK das ukrainische
Volk so eng zusammengerückt ist wie sie
noch nie waren zwischen est und Ost und
West auch zwischen Alt und Jung die
Gesellschaft das darf man nicht
vergessen ist eine Gesellschaft in der
viele ältere ich sage jetzt mal die
Generation 55 plus oder 60 plus ist
in der Sowjetunion auf aufgewachsen und
hat natürlich auch noch nostalgische
Erinnerungen an diese Zeit an die eigene
Jugend und die jungen Menschen die
wollen natürlich nach Westen und kämpfen
für die
Demokratie schon seit 2014 auf dem
meidan ja und du sprichst ja bei deinen
Aufenthalten in der Ukraine mit
wahnsinnig vielen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern wie erlebst du denn die
Stimmung in der Bevölkerung jetzt auf
diesen Winter blicken du hast gerade
schon gesagt der letzte Winter hat die
Menschen sehr zusammenrücken lassen ist
denn davon aktuell noch viel
übrig ja schon absolut und auch den
Humor haben sie oft nicht verloren
ich war vor zwei Wochen schon in parff
da waren erstaunliche 18° tagsüber in
der Sonne zugegeben und auch dort haben
weitere Kaffes geöffnet und das
Besondere an dieser Stadt ist sie ist
nur 40 km entfernt von der russischen
Grenze und von
und Flugabwehr
in hakif ist unter besonderem Stress
weil die Raketen natürlich nicht weit
fliegen müssen wir haben es da selbst
erlebt
dass meistens wenn ein Luftangriff
stattfindet der Einschlag Schlag
stattfindet bevor ähm die der Luftalarm
losgeht ähm die Menschen sind ähm die
ich getroffen habe weiterhin
ähm vollkommen überzeugt dass sie gar
keine andere Wahl haben sie haben
erlebt was Russland in den Gebieten
verrichtet hat die sie in der Ukraine
erobert hat sie haben jetzt noch Kontakt
zu Verwandten und Bekannten die unter
russisch besetzten Gebieten leben und
sie wissen wie das System Putin
funktioniert und diese Diktatur in der
wollen sie nicht leben und deswegen
entscheiden Sie sich für die egal wie
müde sie sind egal
wie auch wie viel wirtschaftliche
Probleme sie zum Teil haben und wie
lange sie auch schon von ihren Familien
getrennt sind ich Ken Leute die haben
ihre Kinder jetzt schon seit anderthalb
Jahren nicht mehr wiedergesehen weil
aber sind trotzdem froh weil sie leben
in Sicherheit im Westen in Europa
ich glaube nicht dass die dieses Volk so
schnell schnell aufgbt belegt wurde das
jetzt auch durch eine
paneluntersuchung von dem soziologischen
Institut hier in kiefev das
festgestellt hat dass die Ukrainer ihren
eigenen Staat deutlich positiver
bewerten als vor dem Krieg und das ist
schon sehr
erstaunlich ja das ist eine ziemlich
starke Aussage danke dar dass du bei uns
warst und alles Gute nach
Kiev
ja so viel zum gesellschaftlichen
Ausblick auf diesen Winter der ansteht
und wir möchten jetzt noch mal auf die
militärische Seite auf den militärischen
Aspekt in diesem Winter schauen und das
tun wir noch mal gemeinsam mit Oberst
Reisner der uns wieder zugeschaltet ist
hallo Herr
Reisner guten
Abend Herr Reisner welche Erwartungen
haben Sie denn an diesen Winter und die
drohenden russischen Angriff auf die
ukrainische
Infrastruktur ja wir haben gesehen im
letzten Winter beginnend mit dem 10
Oktober dass die russische Seite
versucht hat eine strategische
luftkampagne gegen die Ukraine
durchzuführen das Ziel war die kritische
Infrastruktur und das ein bisschen
erklärbar zu machen sie müssen sich
vorstellen die Ukraine hat ein
besonderes Stromnetz sie hat ein
sogenanntes 750 KVA Netz das kommt auch
aus der Zeit der Sowjetunion wo die
nicht wenigen ukrainischen Reaktoren
Strom geliefert haben auch in die
Nachbar Länder und diese 750 kvleitung
das müssen Sie sich vorstellen wie eine
Autobahn und wenn sie von der Autobahn
auf die Bundesstraße fahren dieser
Knotenpunkt diese Abzweigung das ist das
Umspannwerk und das setzt sich fort
quasi bis auch zur Versorgung in die
Haushalte und dass die Russen versuchen
ist nicht diese Autobahnen zu
unterbrechen sondern sie versuchen diese
Knotenpunkte zu zerstören auch gar nicht
so sehr die Kraftwerke sondern genau
diese Knotenpunkte und dort befinden
sich diese Transformer Stationen diese
Transformer und das ist ein sehr
kostbares Gut das sind also sehr große
Objekte die brauchen sie zum Teil in der
Bestellungen in der Vorbereitung und in
der Produktion bis zu zwei Jahre und
werden dann im dritten Jahr geliefert
das bekommen sie nicht so einfach und
das hat sehr schmerzhafte Folgen gehabt
für die Ukraine letztes Jahr wo
schätzungsweise zwischen 50 und 60% der
Infrastruktur aufgrund der Zerstörung
dieser Knotenpunkte zerstört worden ist
die Ukraine hat unglaubliches geleistet
sie hat also ca 10 bis 15% wieder
instand gesetzt sie hat Reserven
gebildet sie versucht auch durch Härtung
der unmittelbaren Umgebung diese Objekte
die Sie zu schützen und natürlich durch
das heransehen von fliegeabhör man kann
gut erkennen dass die russische Seite um
diese Ziele jetzt wieder anzugreifen in
den letzten Wochen versucht hat durch
den Einsatz verringerter Anzahl von
marchalokörpern und iranischer Drohnen
herauszufinden wie ist die ukrainische
luftabehr strukturiert wo sind
Schwergewichte wo nicht damit sie quasi
Lücken findet wo sie dann massiert
zuschlagen kann was bedeutet massiert
massiert bedeutet das Schaffen einer
sogenannten Übersättigung sie sehen auf
eine Kombination von Angriffen von
Marschflugkörpern oder ballistischen
Raketen und vor allem von billigen
iranischen Drohnen die dazu führen
sollen dass die fliegerf der Ukraine
sich verschießt dass alle ihre Raketen
verbraucht und dann diese marchlkörper
durchbrechen können das ist vor allem
deswegen prekär weil Russland
mittlerweile eine eigene Fabrik baut zur
Erzeugung dieser iranischen Drohne man
nimmt anders ca im Monat 200 Stück dort
vom Band laufen sollen und diese Drohnen
und diese Raketen die bereitgestellten
ukrainische militärnachrichtendienst sag
ca 1000 wir haben jetzt gerade Beiter
gehört ca 800 dass die müssen natürlich
abgeschossen werden denn es reicht nicht
wenn von Z raket neuen abgeschossen
werden wenn die zehnte genau dieses
Umspannwerk diesen Transformer trifft
dann ist natürlich das Dilemma da dann
ist dieser Knotenpunkt zerstört und das
ist die große Angst die man natürlich
hier auf ukrainischer Seite berechtigt
aus militärischer Sicht dort
hat ja sie sagen es gerade
drohenfabriken auf der russischen Seite
und hier aus der Community fragt auch
direkt jemand Rheinmetall oder KMW
wollen doch eine Rüstungsfabrik in der
Ukraine bauen wie ist der Stand der
Dinge wie schnell könnte sich die
Ukraine selbst mit Panzern hantter und
links z.B
versorgen nun das Wichtige ist dass die
Ukraine einen funktionierenden
militärischen industriellen Komplex hat
und die Lebensader der Stoff der quasi
diesen am lebenhält das ist quasi im
Prinzip wie beim Blutkreislauf das Blut
der Strom der Strom ist das Wesentliche
Mittel im 21 Jahrhundert um diese
Maschinen zu betreiben und das versucht
die Ukraine die Ukraine versucht quasi
die Tiefe des Raumes das Hinterlands zu
schützen um Wasi hier diese Produktion
aufrechtzuhalten und das ist nicht so
einfach weil eben die Russen genau
versuchen dort im Prinzip anzusetzen und
diese kritische Infrastruktur zu
zerstören das zweite ist man darf sich
nicht vorstellen dass in Zeiten des
Krieges es eine große Fabrik gibt die
arbeitet sondern das Ziel ist z eine
eine Dezentralisierung durchzuführen das
heißt da wird in vielen kleinen
Hinterhöfen in kleinen fabriksobjekten
zum Teil innerhalb von zerstörten
Objekten getan produziert und dann wird
an einer Stelle all die einzelnen
Bestandteile zusammengeholt und dann
wird quasi montiert und zusammengebaut
das ist auch der Grund warum die Ukraine
immer wieder erfolgreich auch selbst
Drohnen baut die sie quasi auch Richtung
Russland schickt im Wesentlichen aber
die Herausforderung ist quasi die
Synchronisation die Logistik diese
Dezentralisierung um so quasi diese
Erfolge tatsächlich möglich zu machen
natürlich kann das dann nicht in diesem
Ausmaß passieren in der Produktion wie
das in einem großen Werk wäre z.B im
Panzerwerk hakif das nicht rund um die
Uhr in mehreren Schichten fahren kann
weil sie e unter dieser permanenten quas
russischen luftbedrohung im Prinzip sich
natürlich großen Gefahren ausgesetzt
sehen ein anderer Punkt der für beide
Seiten wichtig ist ist natürlich die
Munition es gibt ja jetzt zahlen während
die EU nur knapp einen Drittel der bis
März versprochenen 1 Million
Artilleriegeschosse geliefert hat
scheinen die Russen gerade mehr zu
produzieren als sie verbrauchen
oder genau das habe ich auch immer
wieder hingewiesen das Problem ist wir
haben es sehr rasch gesehen dass wir in
einem abnützungskrieg sind und der
abnützungskrieg wird bestimmt durch die
Ressourcen die Ukraine war immer dann
erfolgreich wenn sie beweglich war wenn
die russische Seite aber sie in den
Stellungskampf gezwungen hat hat
Russland seinen großen Vorteil
ausspielen können und das war vor allem
der Einsatz der Artillerie und das ist
jetzt Russland zweimal gelungen letztes
Jahr im Sommer das war dann auch das
Ergebnis das wir gesehen haben bei der
Schlacht um Lise schansk und S donzk und
jetzt wieder quasi nach der Offensive
die die Ukraine versucht hat im Sommer
wo wir genauso wieder diese stfronen
haben und wenn wir uns ansahlen die
Zahlen die kolpotiert werden so hören
wir dass letztes Jahr C 10 Millionen
artilleriranaten verschossen worden sind
eine unglaubliche Zahl die sie an die
Zeit des Ersten Weltkrieges erinnert und
dass die munitionsproduktion der
russischen Seite konservativen Schätzung
entsprechend ca 2 Millionen Granaten
betragen soll auf der anderen Seite
haben wir die Herausforderung dass
Europa hier eigentlich massive Maßnahmen
setzen müsste um hier gleich zu ziehen
man hat hier angekündigt eine Million
Granaten zu liefern bis Ende des Jahres
nun musste man sich eingestehen dass es
hier Herausforderungen gibt die einzigen
die wirklich versucht haben die
Produktion anzuwerfen das ist die USA
die USA hat versucht die monatliche
ausstoßrate vor allem dieser
entscheidenden 155 mm Munition zu
erhöhen aber die USA ist natürlich auch
zur Zeit gefordert nicht wenige Stück
von dieser Munition wieder nach Israel
zu sehen also auch hier wurden knapp
60.000 Stück vor kurzem geliefert weil
auch die israelische armeenen Bedarf hat
und das zeigt dass Europa sich immer
mehr die Frage stellen muss wie man in
diesem Krieg weitermacht ob man
möglicherweise erkennen sollte dass es
tatsächlich darum geht massiv quasi eine
Unterstützung für die Ukraine
durchzuführen oder auch nicht ja und ein
Thema was in dieser Debatte um westliche
Unterstützung immer wieder aufkommt zum
ein in der öffentlichen Debatte aber
auch gerade bei uns hier im Chat sind
die Taurus marschflug hier fragt jemand
aus der Community glauben Sie die
Lieferung von Taurus Marschflugkörpern
können den Kriegsverlauf entscheidend
verändern zu Gunsten der Ukraine ist
auch ein Thema was heute im Bundestag
wieder besprochen
wurde ja wie gesagt ich habe das schon
einmal erwähnt ich möchte mir hier als
Österreicher nicht anmassen ihnen quasi
zu sagen was sie zu tun haben sehen sie
mich quasi wie einen Arzt der inen einen
zweiten Befund zu einer Medikation gibt
im Wesentlichen ob sie wirksam ist oder
nicht natürlich ist es so dass die
Taurus besondere Fähigkeiten hat und das
W gerade jetzt wo es also erkennbar ist
dass die Russen sich in einer
vorbereitenden Phase für diese
Luftschläge befinden sie genau das
Waffensystem wäre das auf entsprechende
Distanz sehr präzise wirken kann und
möglicherweise genau diese
bereitgestellten Marschflugkörper in
unterirdischen Depots zerstören kann ob
es funktioniert oder nicht das weiß man
erst dann wenn man sie eingesetzt hat
und es tatsächlich Erfolg gezeigt hat
oder nicht darum ist es auch sehr
schwierig zu sagen macht das jetzt
diesen Unterschied oder nicht was ganz
wichtiges zu verstehen und das ist ein
Denkfehler das wir in den letzten
Monaten immer wieder angewandt haben
weil wir oft also zu wenig aus meiner
Sicht der Militärs auch zuhören jedes
Waffensystem kann nur funktionieren wenn
es eingebettet ist in verscherderen
Subsystemen nur gemeinsam können sie
ihre wirkungenfalten der Leopard alleine
die attackams alleine das wird nicht das
Ergebnis bringen dass wir uns wünschen
sondern wir brauchen die Subsysteme zur
gleichen Zeit gemeinsam und dann können
Sie diesen entscheidenden Erfolg
erzielen darum investiert man ja
jahrelange Ausbildung in die Ausbildung
der Offiziere aber auch der Unterführer
damit Sie genau dieses Zusammenwirken
erreichen können
ja immerhin hat Deutschland ja zugesagt
die ukrainehilfen für nächstes Jahr zu
verdoppeln was in der Ukraine sehr
wohlwollend aufgenommen wurde wir haben
jetzt hier ganz schön rit durch
verschiedene Aspekte ähm durchgeführt
ich schaue gerade noch mal in den Chat
wie wir das Ganze gut abschließen können
hier fragt jemand perspektivisch in die
Zukunft wie sieht denn die Aussicht für
den nächsten frühlinghaus Frühling aus
ist überhaupt noch genug personalberit
um sich gegen die Russen zu stellen oder
eine Offensive zu
starten ja diese Frage müssen wir uns
beantworten wenn man natürlich dran
überlegen was denn das Ziel dieses
Krieges sein soll und das Ziel dieses
Krieges das hat die Ukraine vorgegeben
und solange die Ukraine an diesem Ziel
nicht abrückt ist es das Ziel das S auch
verfolgt und das ist die Befreiung der
von Russland besetzten Gebiete inklusive
der Ken unabhängig davon ob diese Ziele
möglicherweise mal etwas kürzer gesteckt
werden oder auch nicht der Punkt ist
wenn Sie diese Ziele erreichen möchte
dann kann sie nicht verharen inent
langang einer festen Front sondern sie
muss wieder in die Bewegung gehen und
das nächste Zeitfenster dafür wird
automatisch natürlich das früher sein
das heißt parallel zu dem Umstand dass
die Ukraine versuchen muss sich jetzt
wasas über den Winter zu bringen die
kritische Infrastruktur zu halalten muss
es sich auch wieder konsolidieren neue
Kräfte zusammenführen ausgestattet mit
Waffensystemen die bereitgestellt werden
wieder in die wieder in die Offensive zu
gehen ich weiß das klingt jetzt
natürlich sehr mühsam und langwierig
aber denken Sie an die Geschichte es war
immer eineinanderreihung von offensiven
bis schlussendlich eine Seite obsegt hat
oder auch nicht das erinnert ja auch
immer sie an den Ersten Weltkrieg wo wir
genau diese Zeit hatten zuerst die
Ernüchterung weil eben damals die Jungs
nicht zu Weihnachten nach Hause gekommen
sind dann das Jahr 1915 wo man erkannt
hat okay wir müssen jetzt in die
Kriegswirtschaft investieren wir haben
eentlich nur mehr Reservisten an der
Front und so weiter und so fort D das
Jahr der elenden offensiven hier drängen
sich ja viele Vergleiche auf geschichte
wiederholt sich nicht aber sie folgt
denelben Mustern wir tun uns nur sehr
schwer das zu verstehen weil es uns
einfach völlig fremd war wir haben damit
eigentlich abgeschlossen nach Ende des
Kalten Krieges wir dachten Francis Yama
das Ende der Geschichte des Scorpions
the wind of change und jetzt hat es uns
mit aller Urgewalt erwischt und wir
stehen hier und müssen jetzt
Entscheidungen treffen die
möglicherweise für Europa in den
nächsten Jahren entscheidend sein werden
Oberst Reisner hier noch mal mit der
großen historischen Klammer in der
dieser Krieg auch steht Herr Reisner
vielen Dank dass Sie meine Fragen und
die Fragen der Community beantwortet
haben ich bin mir sicher dass wir uns
hier an dieser Stelle noch das ein oder
andere mal wiedersehen werden schönen
Abend und alles Gute nach Wien
herzlichen Dank für Zeit und Vertrauen
und auf
Wiedersehen ja so viel zu unserem
Ukraine Update zur militärischen Lage
ich hoffe ihr konntet einiges mitnehmen
vielen Dank für eure zahlreichen Fragen
und Kommentare und bis zum nächsten Mal
wenn ihr wollt bei ZF heute live beim
Ukraine Update wir sind auf jeden Fall
weiterhin für euch im Einsatz schönen
Abend euch
[Musik]
noch